this is a story about an incredible
primate
highly sociable
extremely affectionate
and very vocal
the golden snub-nosed monkey
[Music]
it's home
China's remote Mountain forests
China is a realm of diverse Landscapes
[Music]
full of rare and surprising creatures
for the first time we'll uncover their
remarkable
untold stories
[Music]
in the Hidden Kingdoms
China
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
golden snub-nosed monkey
she's just a few hours old
and entirely dependent on her mother
[Music]
in the year ahead she'll be at her most
vulnerable and will face many challenges
she'll need intelligence
strength
and most of all her families care and
love
if she's to survive in China's Mountain
Forest Kingdom
thank you
the endangered golden snub-nosed monkey
lives only in the high mountain forests
of central China
[Music]
up to 13
000 feet above sea level
our baby girls troop lives in the
world's largest high altitude Forest
where there are more tree species than
in any other deciduous forest on Earth
[Music]
it's spring
and the monkeys are in High Spirits
The Troop has five families
each with one male
several females
and they're young
[Music]
males that aren't part of the family
live in the troops Bachelor gang
[Music]
they're a boisterous bunch
but right now
they're not the center of attention
[Music]
that honor belongs to our baby girl
she's the first born this spring
and the females in the family will do
anything to get a cuddle
[Music]
this auntie is first in line
but not for long
only one baby to go around
[Music]
competition is fierce
[Music]
when it all gets a bit too much
it's Mom to the rescue
[Music]
thank you
the monkey's attention soon turns to
their tummies
in Spring they spend a quarter of
daylight hours eating fresh new leaves
their favorite food and an important
source of protein
as temperatures rise
trees higher up the mountains spring to
life
and the monkeys follow the feast
Crystal Clear streams run through these
high Forest valleys
the surrounding trees filter the rain
and their shade keeps the water cool
helping to maintain healthy levels of
dissolved oxygen
these pristine streams are a lifeline
and not just for the monkeys
one of China's strangest creatures lives
here
the Chinese giant salamander has hardly
changed since the Jurassic period over
170 million years ago
[Music]
growing up to six feet long it's the
largest amphibian in the world
[Music]
this female has tiny eyes and poor
vision
relying instead on smell touch and
sensing vibrations to get around
she spends most of her life underwater
absorbing oxygen through her skin
folds increase the surface area
maximizing the process
although revered for centuries in China
illegal hunting and habitat Destruction
has left these creatures critically
endangered in the wild
[Music]
for the few who remain remote Forest
streams like this are a vital Refuge
[Music]
foreign
and exploring her Forest Home
[Music]
she soon discovers that she shares it
with other creatures
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
but it's the family's playful youngsters
that really catch her eye
[Music]
a year or two older than her their lives
seem like one endless play session
and she's eager to try out some of the
skills they've mastered
hanging from one arm is best tried close
to the ground to begin with
[Music]
walking along a branch looks easy
but for our baby it takes concentration
bravery
and brain power
[Music]
she's figuring out
how to turn around
[Music]
get back to Mom
a moment of comfort
foreign
[Music]
babies learn very quickly
and soon
she's climbing trees
[Applause]
by following her instincts and imitating
others she's grasping essential monkey
skills
spring is when all the new babies are
born
it offers them the best chance of
survival
as they'll have the warmer months to
grow strong
but in this High Mountain Forest
nothing is guaranteed
Spring weather can change in an instant
a sudden drop in temperature
threatens all the troops babies
in China's high mountain forests spring
rain brings a sudden drop in temperature
our baby girl doesn't yet have a full
coat to protect her from the cold and
wet
alone in the Treetops
she's vulnerable to hypothermia
[Music]
her mom and family step in
to keep her warm and dry
but as the weather worsens
rain turns to snow
disaster strikes the family
[Music]
a mother cradles the lifeless body of
her newborn baby
[Music]
foreign
she cares for her infant as though it's
still alive
[Music]
family members try to comfort her
[Music]
but she seeks solitude
these monkeys seem to understand death
[Music]
and this mother isn't ready to let go
foreign
returns
and life flourishes once more in the
mountain forests
in time spring turns to Summer
[Music]
trees are in full bloom
and food is plentiful
this area has more than 4 000 plant
species
making these forests among the most
biologically diverse on Earth
with food in such easy reach
there's plenty of time for other
activities
such as grooming
an all-important part of monkey Society
it keeps skin infer clean
but more importantly builds and cements
relationships
and it's just so relaxing
nap time soon follows
our baby girl doesn't doze for long
[Music]
at three months old with stronger
muscles and hand-eye coordination
she's coming on Leaps and Bounds
[Music]
and she's taking a big step in her
Social Development
playing with other babies
[Music]
[Music]
but at this age she's soon distracted
and wanders off exploring
[Music]
as the adults doze in the afternoon sun
a cold-blooded killer is waking up
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
a king rat snake is heading towards our
baby girl
this constrictor eats any creature it
can wrap itself around
[Music]
thank you
the alarm is raised
[Music]
many pairs of eyes help keep the monkeys
safe
foreign
moves on
in this complex society these
intelligent monkeys use many different
vocalizations
as the families and Bachelor gang travel
together
contact calls keep them all in touch
individuals have their own unique
signature calls
particularly useful in dense vegetation
when they can't see each other well
they have lots to talk about in their
ever-changing world
[Music]
and the seasons are turning once more
[Music]
fall is arriving
one of the most Spectacular times of
year
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
at six months old
our baby girl still depends on mom's
milk
but she's also developing a taste for
new things
she takes her first bites of solid food
tries her hand at grooming
and she spends more time than ever
playing
[Music]
ten times more than she did in summer
[Music]
playing is fun but it's important too it
keeps the monkeys fit and strong
enhances their social skills and
sharpens their brains
[Music]
as long as they get the landing right
in Chinese folklore monkeys represent
rebellion and mischief
one group that lives up to that
reputation is the troops Bachelor gang
these young males were evicted from
their families before they turned three
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
they wrestle endlessly
preparing for the day they'll fight to
try to win their own family
one of the older Bachelors has reached
that point
[Music]
aged seven the warts on his lips show
that he's sexually mature
[Music]
apparently these warts are attractive to
females
he'll win the right to mate if he can
take over a family
[Music]
he's going to try to overthrow our baby
girl's dad
dad and his family are under threat
males who take over have been known to
kill babies so that they can sire their
own offspring
[Music]
our baby girl could be his grave Danger
a challenger is battling our baby girl's
dad
hoping to take over his family
if he wins he could kill her
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dad's an experienced fighter but not as
young and strong as he used to be
[Music]
what he does have
is the support of his females
[Music]
[Music]
the Challenger is sent packing
dad returns to our baby girl's mom for
comfort
[Music]
it's thanks to the females that he's
kept his position in the family
including his mating rights
fall is the breeding season
and the female who lost her baby in
Spring is ready to mate again
to win the male's affections she showers
him with attention
foreign
female golden snub-nosed monkeys use
grooming as currency hoping to exchange
it for sex
[Music]
and she seems to be finding all the
right spots
foreign
[Music]
they'll mate several times
but only time will tell if she'll give
birth next spring
[Music]
with fall progressing in China's forests
trees shed their leaves
a way to save energy during the cold
months ahead
[Music]
with less on offer the monkeys eat
bamboo leaves
and pine needles
all the forests creatures get ready for
winter
[Music]
this remote high altitude Refuge is home
to over 90 mammal species
but most are secretive and seldom seen
yellow-throated Martin searched the
forest floor for fallen fruit and seeds
[Music]
the forest provides this vital food
source and the Martins return the favor
traveling far and wide they spread seeds
through their droppings
[Music]
and seeds disperse in more than one way
foreign
coats
[Music]
in Fall the monkeys travel up to two
miles each day spreading the seeds as
they go
the forest plants and animals depend on
one another for survival
foreign
[Music]
and with a thicker coat she's ready for
the harshest time of year
[Music]
she seems fascinated by the first Snows
of winter
and explores her Frosty world
what she doesn't yet know
is that four months of snow lies ahead
to get through it she'll need to master
a new skill you unique to these monkeys
[Music]
thank you
as winter temperatures plummet
our baby girl seeks comfort and warmth
with her mom
[Music]
they can't escape the cold
in fact these monkeys tolerate the
coldest average temperatures of any
non-human primate on the planet
[Music]
their dense golden coats thicken up in
winter
covering their hands
feet
and those strange snubbed noses are less
exposed to frostbite
they also have another remarkable
adaptation
[Music]
they're the only monkeys in the world
known to travel on two legs in snow
[Music]
foreign
foreign
s off the cold ground
[Music]
and helps them travel faster
reducing the time they spend in contact
with the icy snow
[Music]
our baby girl reaches another milestone
as she gets the hang of this new skill
[Music]
[Music]
this unique Behavior could be the source
of an ancient Chinese Legend
s forests are said to be home to Wild
men
mysterious ape-like figures with red
hair
who walk upright through the trees
sounds a lot like the golden snub-nosed
monkey
thank you
or maybe there really are unknown and
mysterious wild men roaming these
forests
to escape the freezing temperatures in
China's forests some creatures hibernate
and others migrate
for those who stick around
having a strategy is vital
this little guy is a sable
rarely seen or filmed he's a smaller
cousin of the yellow-throated Martin
today he's out hunting
using his Keen sense of smell and sharp
hearing to search for small prey
large snowshoe-like feet help him travel
lightly on top of the deep snow
winter is the hardest time to find food
but he's got that covered
when times were good he stockpiled food
Underground
the survival strategy is a lifesaver
[Music]
to generate enough body heat to stay
alive the monkeys now need more calories
than at any other time of year
[Applause]
carbohydrate-rich bark and lichens
become their main source of food
diverse gut organisms in a
multi-chambered stomach help them digest
this tough diet
as winter reaches its coldest point
the temperature plunges to minus four
degrees Fahrenheit
freeze today
you need another way to stay warm
foreign
our baby girl and family struggle in
Sub-Zero temperatures
[Music]
but luckily they have another way to
keep warm
foreign
[Music]
body heat
[Music]
[Applause]
these affectionate monkeys huddle all
year round
but they do it much more in winter
their lives depend on being surrounded
by family
[Music]
fellow bachelors
[Music]
our baby girl hides out in the warmest
spot
[Music]
until it's safe to venture out again
[Music]
foreign
silence is finally broken
[Music]
it's a time of transformation and
celebration
[Music]
monkeys have lost body weight
but their favorite food is growing again
foreign
[Music]
as grown up as she's become
she still returns frequently to Mom for
milk and comfort
she won't be fully weaned for another
year when her mom gives birth again
and even then they'll likely stay close
for a few more years
[Music]
the cycle of Life keeps turning
to grow
[Music]
female that lost her baby last spring
has a new arrival
already two weeks old he healthy and
strong
[Music]
our yearling girl is eager to introduce
herself to her new little cousin
[Music]
no longer the baby she knows that in the
future he'll be a playmate and someone
she can help care for
[Music]
one day she'll likely become a mother
herself
and continue the long line of these
extraordinary monkeys
living in China's Hidden Forest Kingdom
[Music]
[Music]